[Applause]
it is time for drew's news the only news
that feels like baked ziti for the soul
oh god i could eat baked ziti every day
and with me at the desk is the best
co-pilot in the biz rossi ross matthew
hi everybody hi
and it's pasta week
it is pasta week
my favorite week your total favorite
happy pasta week everybody
yes i know
and in today's noodle news yes guess who
dolly parton has just revealed the
secret to her mac and cheese and you're
not ready for this ron i am not ready
when i read what her secret was i mean i
love dolly parton she can do no wrong
but i was like maybe this is her first
misstep ever
insider reports dolly never serves mac
and cheese without get this
fried apples
and this unique combo platter happened
by accident one time dolly was just
making mac and cheese my soul sister
and tossed in some leftover fried apples
i've never tried that yeah and she had
them lying around and she never looked
back rossi well she wrote islands in the
stream so she had to try apples in the
cheese that's what she had to do
it it makes my brain go
it doesn't make any sense like apple
well then i thought but people do put
cheddar cheese on their apple pie i've
never done that have you guys do that
that's a thing people do that i am so
excited because we have some here okay
i'm gonna try if it's if dolly can do it
i can do it
oh my god
[Applause]
it's apple pie with cheese she actually
has
it
the mac and cheese is is secondary to
the apple in the most
complimentary and confident way
i want to say this right now on
television dolly parton i've never been
more wrong in my entire life
this is how it should be there's the
apples are cooked down with cinnamon and
then mixed in that cheese is so
delicious you guys it's um
dolly
dolly you did it again
and the best news is ross it's your
story oh
that bowl of mac and cheese is going to
be gone by the end of this story all
right everyone less than a month after
retiring from the nfl tom brady has
announced his next venture is he moving
on to another team what is he doing no
the hollywood reporter says tom is
taking on hollywood and when the seven
time super bowl champ makes a play oh he
goes big he'll be producing and
appearing in a football road trip movie
he'd help develop called 80 for brady
and listen to the cast he's got
hollywood's biggest icons to star in it
lily tomlin jane fonda rita moreno
and sally field
uh that's quite a cast and they're going
to play a group of uh best friends on a
road trip to see the 2017 super bowl uh
which is the one that tom brady came
back and beat the um uh falcons last
minute remember that super bowl uh and
uh i have to say getting sally field and
tom brady together and jane fonda
this proves that prayer works okay
because this is everything i've ever
wanted i you know someone said upstairs
like
speaking of dolly parton where's dolly
you have two-thirds of the holy trinity
of nine to five you're right you're
right tomlin and jane fonda and i
thought oh you're right where's dolly
and then i found out
that dolly parton is actually gonna come
in and do an episode of grace and
frankie oh really so there is hope she
will make an appearance in this yes
please that's a great idea
[Music]
you